series on the new normal we look at how
the pandemic is dramatically changing
our everyday lives those changes affect
the way we work learn socialize and even
vote after weeks of social distancing
most of us had had I've had our routines
completely up ended well James James
clears best-selling book atomic habits
it's an easy and proven way to build
good habits and break bad ones and he
joins us now with something that we all
need ways to create new and healthy
routines during this crisis James good
morning it's been pointed out that right
now all of us are simultaneously in
essence breaking our addiction with the
normal that was we're in withdrawal and
we've got to come up with a new way of
running our lives with everything
changed how do we start from nothing and
build healthy habits again yeah it's a
great question
any time the environment changes in a
big way behaviors gonna change in a big
way and we all have had our environments
and context shifted in ways that we
didn't expect so two of the things that
you can focus on if you want to build
better habits during this time period -
the first things to do are to make it
obvious and to make it easy so as an
example you know I have wanted to use
this time during lockdown to try to
foster a reading habit more and so I'm
sort of sprinkled books around the house
they're on my desk in the office they're
next to my bed they're on the living
room table but then I've also taken
audible and moved it to the home screen
on my phone so it's the first thing that
I see and those are ways of making that
habit more obvious and easy to do and
that whole concept which I call
environment design just trying to make
the good habit the path of least
resistance that's something you can
employ for almost any happier trying to
build and certainly can be useful as we
need to redesign the environments that
we live and work in right now but James
this is the thing I just think the day's
all run together Tom Hanks said it best
recently when he said today is today all
day long I kept saying I'm gonna get on
the treadmill gonna get on the treadmill
and never did never did and I'm sitting
there really sitting just paralyzed at
the kitchen table so what do we do to
stay on track to keep our regular
routine or exercising routine it's so do
yeah hi Gail it's um it's a good
question you know I think we all have
felt that the the philosophy or the
mantra that I like to keep in mind is
reduce the scope but stick to the
schedule
you know you you don't really want to
have you won't have like no zero days
you know zero day is something where you
don't do anything you don't show up you
don't get one rep in or write one
sentence or whatever and it's hard right
now because people are missing the
habits that they had before you know we
wish we could go to our old gym and see
our friends or to our favorite coffee
shop and journal like we always do but
because we don't have that doesn't mean
that we can't do anything and so I think
rather than trying to achieve high
performance right now the place to focus
is rather to avoid airs to try to invert
it to not put up a zero day to reduce
the scope and stick to the schedule to
realize that you can't you know maybe
write as much as you wanted to do but
you can write one sentence and maybe you
don't do the 45 minute workout like you
normally do but you can do one pushup
and those sound like small things and
they are in the sense of their action
they're easy to do but they count for a
lot because they cast a vote for the
type of person you want to become they
help reinforce that identity they give a
signal to yourself that the situation is
not ideal the circumstance is not
perfect but I was still able to show up
and be the kind of person that I want to
be and so I think that idea of scaling
down but not having a zero-day I think
is important to keep in mind during this
time James I think that's a wonderful
point it's it's about shifting your
focus and redefining success for these
new conditions that we're living in one
of the things that I think is really
interesting in what you proposed is
regardless of a person's goals they can
do something called habit stacking to
reach those goals can you tell us what
habit stacking is and how it could help
us achieve our ends yeah so this is a
great strategy originally designed by BJ
Foggs a professor at Stanford and his
big insight is that a good way to build
a new habit is to stack it on top of an
old one so let's say that you already
make a cup of coffee every morning and
you're feeling stressed and uncertain by
the current situation and so you're
telling yourself I'd be great if I could
build a meditation habit well
what fogg recommends is you essentially
take say after my current habit so after
i drink a cup of coffee i will meditate
for 60 seconds and the key is choosing a
small and easy to do habit and then
layering it on top of those things that
you already do that you can rely on that
you know are gonna be sort of like an
anchor in your day and what it does and
what i think is useful about it is that
it gives you a very clear and easy place
to insert that habit into your life you
know a lot of people feel like oh i if i
have more motivation i would stick to my
habits or if I had better discipline or
willpower if I really wanted it but I'm
not sure if that's quite right I think
many people feel like what they lack is
motivation when what they really lack is
clarity and habit stacking helps make it
very clear when and where new behavior
is going to occur and so you simply do
that by stacking the new behavior on top
of an old one I love that there are
these great jokes on line right now of
people day one quarantine everyone's got
it all put together day 30 of quarantine
complete mess maybe they follow your
steps day 60 looking good again all
right James clear thank you very much I